[Music]
i want to say one thing about him before
pat introduces him
uh one serious thing
don rumsfeld is one of the greatest
public servants of our age
i happen to know from peace and stories
together one of them from him
that there was a time in 1980 when
he was instructed to wait by the phone
to see if he'd call to be the vice
president united states
and he came second in that contest
and the history of the country would be
different if that had been done
and better and you'll see why in a
minute
[Applause]
and i've been privileged to know him for
a long time and i
regard that as a great honor
also an honor is to introduce my friend
and the vice chairman of our board pat
sajak
i'm old now and so i've been privileged
to know a lot of very fine people for a
long time
and that's one of the great blessings of
my life and this is
an instance of that
he was born in chicago
he was a kid interested in radio
and broadcasting in general he
did broadcasting in college i'm
confident that john miller and scott
bertram who run our radio program are
going to ask him to come talk to the
radio kids who are studying that
sometime we have a low power station now
in hillsdale
and it's been going actively now for
six or eight weeks john and so far no
scandals
i'm astonished
he joined the army in 1968 he was a
chief dj on armed forces radio in
vietnam
he inherited that job from a famous
man who invented the expression good
morning vietnam and he used to say that
all the time
after the service he became a weatherman
in nashville and then in los
angeles that's where he first came to my
notice because a weird thing happened
a bunch of friends of mine some of the
professors here at the college are
students of those friends
and i were you know in graduate school
together and
you wouldn't believe this but we took a
fancy to watching the weather
you know we would turn on the tv to see
the weather because this weather man was
hilarious
and i'd heard about it like 10 times and
then a man who's now deceased george
forsyth said
we got to turn on the weather and he
turned it on and now i'm watching the
weather and i'm thinking what that's for
and that night the anchor person this
first time i ever saw the man
the anchor person said to him he did the
weather he did it
well i thought and you know the weather
in southern california
[Laughter]
this is the most accurate weatherman in
the country and
he didn't tell any jokes and the
and the anchor was obviously disturbed
about that and said well pat
you've got to tell us one joke and pat
stood
like this i'll always remember
and he said you don't have any jokes and
pets it no
and then it was like 30 seconds and he
didn't say anything
and by then everybody on the set and
everybody in the
crappy apartment where we were watching
the weather we were just laughing like
anything
he never broke a smile and i said
that guy is hilarious
so he got noticed because he was
talented
and uh he had a talk show on cbs the
plot was
late night talk show that johnny carson
was going to retire and they launched
the show and then
johnny carson stayed on another year
which messed things up a bit i sat in
for larry king a lot his talk show was
good
um because he's smart he has
uh interject he took
almost all of the core courses at
hillsdale college
one of them from me and he has a four
point
and we don't like that here and we were
also relieved
when he decided not to continue because
we were wondering who's going to give
him a b
he became a friend he got noticed by
merv griffin
and he put him on this game show
and the game show still goes it's the
most popular game show in history
the most popular syndicated show in
history
that has a lot to do with him
i have met vanna white myself and think
after i met her
she's very lovely woman but
i think it has a lot to do with him
i met him in a restaurant in pasadena a
long time ago i noticed something
first of all he's he's probably the only
person i know
where when he walks down the street
somebody always knows who he is
and of course they stop him in this
restaurant there were like four people
who came up to ask for an autograph
and i have a tip for you i learned only
by knowing him
if you ever do that to anybody
you should just go up and say i really
admire what you do may i disturb you to
get an autograph
because that's polite and and i can tell
you pat
is extremely gracious when that happens
and it must drive him nuts although he
never gives any sign of it
i do know he values his privacy
so what they do walk up and say is well
you know
i'm not a fan but my daughter or my
brother or my sister
and i used to analyze that you know what
why would they do that
i think they were trying to establish
some equality or something
so don't ever i encourage you be guilty
of that go up and praise the person if
you're going to mess up their life
i also learned right away in that dinner
in that lunch conversation which there
were many and of course i've known him a
very long time now
and since i the day i met him i have
actually never done any important thing
in my life that he's not been involved
in
why i value his counsel he's
funny he's the greatest house guest
he just raised the specter he's trying
to bid get bidding up he stays with
penny and me when he comes to town
and of course the chairman is building
that really great house
on manning street and he wondered if
there's going to be a bidding war for
who get who he get who gets to have him
for
dinner and i wondered if he wanted to
remain on the board
i think he'd just go nuclear right out
on things like that
but i can also help with the more
positive thing and that is jan and bill
have invited all of you to stay with
them whenever
you wish to do
they have a really great wine cellar and
bill asked me to tell you that it's
theirs
it's yours you can have it whenever you
want just stop by anytime knock on the
door
i can give you a list of the most
expensive wines if you'd like to have
that with you when you go
pat gave a convocation speech here in
2002
got a standing ovation that's not common
i i have never
done that i don't like him for that but
i can put up with it
he and leslie his wife got an honorary
degree here in 2015.
they have two children patrick and
maggie they're both superstars
patrick's going to be a medical doctor
maggie graduated from princeton of laden
can be whatever she wants to be
from rock star to folk singer
to anything medical doctor whatever she
wants to do
she's uh the family is a testament to
what kind of character
kind of man he is and i delight in this
company always have
and he is a friend of don rumsfeld as
well and i thought it would be right if
he introduced don
please welcome pat sajak
yeah i've still got it
i had i had a lot of clever retorts
prepared but he didn't insult me tonight
so i'm
kind of i'm kind of lost as you get
older
you treasure long term friendships more
and more and i treasure ours and i thank
you larry very much
now our special guest tonight
knows the entire alphabet by heart
i'm sorry that's an old man a white
introduction i apologize
rumsfeld rumsfeld
you can tell a lot about an institution
by the the company it keeps and the
friends
it makes uh donald rumsfeld is a great
friend of hillsdale college has been for
a long time
and on behalf of the board of directors
uh the board of trustees on whom
with whom i'm happy to serve president
arn and all of the students
and the faculty who have benefited from
his generosity we just want to thank him
for all he does for hillsdale thank you
september 11 2001 no doubt one of the
darkest days in the history of this
country and by that evening
men and women in government and without
government
were rolling up their sleeves to work as
hard as they could with a steely resolve
to make sure as best they could that
that would never happen again and if i
could use a do a little editorializing
we've seen what happens when that
resolve
falters donald rumsfeld was secretary of
defense on that dark day as he was
years earlier under president ford he
and his wife of over 60 years a
wonderful woman named joyce
chair of the non-profit rumsfeld
foundation that supports leadership and
public service at home
and the growth of freer political and
economic systems abroad
his memoir is called known and unknown
it was a new york times bestseller and
the profits
from it go to the military charity
supported by his foundation
as do the profits from his app yes the
secretary has an
app it's called churchill solitaire
and it's really terrific i don't know if
any of you have yet do you have it uh
it's
on all the apple and all that uh check
it out and uh and download it and you'll
be
doing some good as well as having some
fun this extraordinary man has been a
naval
aviator a congressman a white house
chief of staff presidential envoy to the
mideast
ceo of two fortune 500 companies and
chairman of a third
and he's a graduate of princeton
university i mentioned that
latter part because it was in that role
that the sajak's and the rumsfeld
came to know each other a little better
as as larry mentioned our our daughter
graduated from hillsdale before she was
about to start four years ago she was a
nervous young lady who was convinced
that there was a clerical error that's
the only reason she got into princeton
we didn't know anyone who had ever been
there she didn't have any friends who
were going
and i remembered having conversations at
events like this with
secretary rumsfeld and knew of his
background and we called him and asked
if he'd mind spending a few minutes with
our daughter
on the phone you know telling her a
little bit about the school instead he
offered and we accepted the offer to
have lunch with joyce and with the
secretary rumsfeld
with my wife and our daughter at a
little family restaurant
uh on the eastern shore of maryland and
he spent a couple of hours talking about
talking about princeton and if you don't
think it's cool to have this
former secretary of defense talk about
dorms with you you don't know what cool
is
maggie felt a lot better about heading
off to school and today this very
afternoon
our daughter dropped us at the airport
where
secretary rumsfeld was waiting and she
had a chance to thank him again
four years later where now she is a
grown woman
and still convinced it was a clerical
error
so i am proud to present
a great public servant and not
incidentally a great guy
donald rumsfeld
let's see how this sounds i got up this
morning
and had lost my voice
and i couldn't find it and i have no
idea where i left it
i um
you know larry on asking for an
autograph
people do that they ask but
almost every person who comes up to me
and said could i please
have an autograph they say it's their
grandmother that likes me
i suppose if you're 84 years old
that happens
i um i am here because i am a fan
i do apologize for my voice can you hear
me in the back all right
all right i um
i'm a fan of
this college i'm a fan of larry yarn
i'm a fan of pats and i thank you for
those
kind words pat i appreciate it
i also like your school motto i i
couldn't read it in latin
and i wonder how many of you could
but um
as i recall uh
it says strength rejoices in the
challenge
you know in business or
government sometimes you say it a little
differently you say
it's your enemies that make you strong
and i think it's an interesting thought
i appreciate the
also the fact that this college stays
true to its values
and the importance of
a history of opposing
discrimination in race and sex
and uh i i think that
staying true to that is has been an
important part of your history and i
congratulate you for it
before turning to questions and i i will
be happy to respond to some questions
let me uh ask a question that i get
asked all the time and that is
what is the gravest threat facing the
united states of america
you get a lot of different answers to
that question
and some people will
say that it's the existence of nuclear
weapons
uh a growing volume of nuclear weapons
others will mention the proliferation of
weapons of mass destruction
some will mention iran and its
support of terrorism as well as its
nuclear program
north korea is a
country with some less than fully stable
leadership which is worrisome
russia's behavior in the crimea
the muscular behavior of the people's
republic of china and the south china
sea
president obama at the coast guard okay
academy this year at graduation said the
gravest threat
facing the young men graduating there
would be global warming
others will talk about the debt and the
the trajectory that we see and and
wonder
if this country will be in the future
what it's been in the past and how can
one do that
if we haven't connected what's going out
with what's with
coming in
cyber warfare is very much in the news
and of course a the most advanced
nations in the world are the most
vulnerable
we we're we're so dependent on digits
we've thrown away the shoe boxes with
three by five cars that
people my age are familiar with
the mass of refugees that are moving
from continent to continent is something
that people look at and
are concerned about they're concerned
obviously from the humanitarian nature
and the fact that people are fleeing
countries not because they want to
but because they're frightened for their
lives and for their families lives
and seeking some place in the world
that's
more hospitable
the growing lethality of weapons
year to year is certainly something that
needs to be
thought about and then there's the
there's something that may not even be
mentioned
a surprise there's a book
on pearl harbor by roberta walsteader
and there's a professor named thomas
shelling who wrote a forward
in the book and and he wrote about
surprise he said
there's a tendency in planning to
confuse the unfamiliar
with the improbable the contingency
we've not considered seriously
looks strange what looks strange is
thought
improbable and what is improbable
need not be considered seriously
the results at pearl harbor he went on
to say were sudden
concentrated and dramatic the failure
however was cumulative
widespread and rather drearily
familiar um
he said the danger is not that we shall
read the signals and
indicators with too little skill the
danger is in a poverty of
expectations a routine obsession with a
few dangers
that may be familiar rather than lightly
it's worth thinking about because
despite all the lists that i mentioned
any one of which is a serious threat to
the country and to the world
the reality is that the
each of those things is talked about
each of those things is on television
in the evening each of those things is
has
people worried about it and concerned
about it and thinking about it
let me suggest a
a totally different thought as to what
might be the gravest danger
and i don't have any idea if i'm right
and if it merits even being on the list
but it strikes me it's worth thinking
about
when i was growing up in the depression
in the 1930s
they didn't have things like iphones and
ipads and
all television
um i know that's a stunning thought
that it's true uh we played with magnets
and marbles and things like that
and one of the things i remember was
with the magnets if you moved a magnet
it could either attract or repel
and you could get metal particles
all moving in one direction
and and as i was thinking about the
gravest threat
the the thing i worry about
is certainly those things on that list
to be sure
but it's because they are all
macro events and the movement of a
metal particle from a magnet is a micro
event
it's not talked about it's not on
television
it's not debated it's not discussed
it's not something that people worry
about really
let me give you some examples we saw the
riots in baltimore
they were on television and the mayor
was talking and the police were
having troubles and people were burning
buildings and what have you
what wasn't on television was
who knows how many but let's say one
spouse went down to a policeman for
breakfast
sat down and said look you've been doing
this for 12 years
you're not getting any support policemen
are being killed
don't you think let's move to phoenix
and
you can go into corporate security or
something
the
think of what the people's republic of
china took a reef
built a port built an airfield and is
now
weaponizing that reef
and i would guess that a parliamentarian
in the phili
in the philippines would take a look at
that
everyone knows about it we also know
that there's been no complaint
despite the fact that all the countries
in that region pacific nations
are members of the law of the sea
so treaty a parliamentarian you're
you're a member of their parliament
and a vote comes up where you can tilt
either towards the west towards
north korea south korea um
japan the united states australia
new zealand singapore or you can tilt
towards the prc
and you kind of look at what's going on
which ways
are things going
and one parliamentarian tilts towards
the prc
in a vote rather than the way he
he or she might have voted that's not
reported
that's not on television
the um
if you're a leader in kazakhstan or
somewhere in central asia
and you see mr putin going into crimea
in ukraine and you see the absence
of any reaction to it
and and you're right there next to
russia
i get asked what do you think mr putin
will do next and my answer is
whatever he can it's not complicated
think of your classes in economics
if you want more of something you reward
it if you want less of it you penalize
it
and he will do whatever he thinks he can
where there's no penalty and there
basically is no penalty
so you're in some country kazakhstan
kurz in kyrgyzstan the republic of
georgia
and you you're wondering which way
things are going
and you make a decision
that you will do something that is
accommodating
to mr putin's muscular behavior
in that part of the world
president of egypt al-sisi gave a speech
and he gave it in the most important
arab city in the world in cairo in the
most important arab country
in the world and he gave it to
the most important group a group of
imams
and he basically said that that
our faith is being hijacked
and we it's those of us in that faith
that are going to have to do something
about it
now we all read what that jihadists do
in the world
blowing up people strapping
suicide vests on young people and
putting him in a shopping center
in a market somewhere in the world
and he gives that speech and no one
noticed no one read it
what one maybe one percent a half a
percent a tenth of a percent of the
people in the united states even
know he did it it was courageous
it was exactly what needed to be said
to exactly the group that needed to hear
it in exactly the country
and it wasn't noticed instead what do we
do
we kind of give
egypt trouble about parts for the
weapons we've sold them
what if you're an imam and a leader in
in
indonesia and you saw that speech
and you said that was courageous his
predecessor sadat was killed
by an offshoot of the muslim brotherhood
sadat went to israel he put a target on
his forehead and he got killed
and lccc gave a speech
and put a target on his forehead and
nobody
cared nobody stood up and supported him
again a micro
event in fact
it we mostly read about actions
not not the absence of a reaction
to that action my point is
is simple i don't know but i think it's
conceivable
that the total weight
of all of those micro events across the
globe
put together might weigh more
in terms of it their importance than
anything
on that list that i read
it's conceivable that all of those
little acts
or absence of acts
that are taking place all across the
globe
all of those metallic particles that are
turning away
when we create a vacuum in the world a
leadership
vacuum it gets filled nature abhors a
vacuum it gets filled
by people who don't have our interest
they don't have our values
and quite apart from not having our
interests or our values they often don't
wish
well those of us that do have those
interests
or those values and that's what's
happening
in the globe i
i think about the
how hard that is to think about it we
we don't know how to add that up we
don't know where to rank it
we don't know where to put it on that
list of things we have to worry about
but dr shelling's
forward in the book on pearl harbor
talking about surprise one of the things
he says is something about a
failure of imagination
and and it seems to me it's so easy
today
for us to have a failure of imagination
about the kinds of things i've mentioned
and i think everyone here could think of
5 10 15 more examples just like the ones
i mentioned
that are not on television
they aren't being talked about and they
aren't even
part of the equation but i would submit
that we ought to at least consider the
possibility
that the weight and magnitude of all of
those things taking place
all across the globe might
weigh more and constitute a as greater
even a greater danger
to our country and our interests
and our values
the um i'm
from the midwest too and i'm an optimist
i guess and i
i think about the future of this
wonderful country
and uh its direction
i uh
when i was in college at our senior
banquet
the governor from my home state of
illinois spoke a man named adlai
stevenson
he'd been governor he ran against
dwight eisenhower and 52
and lost and he ran against dwight
eisenhower and 56 and lost and he was
and i voted for eisenhower even though
the speech he gave at my senior banquet
is on my website which i've creatively
named rumsfeld.com
so if any of you know a young person who
wants to read a speech that i found
truly inspiring the one by natalie
stevenson at our senior banquet
you can go to the website and get it but
he basically said that
the power for good or evil of the
american political organization
is virtually beyond measurement
the decisions it makes the uses to which
it devotes its immense resources
the leadership which it provides on
moral as well as material questions
all appear likely to determine the fate
of the modern world
this was back in 1954.
he said all of this is to say that your
power
as individuals is virtually
beyond measurement for it is to you
to your enlightened attention the
american government must look for the
sources of its power
and he said you dare not withhold your
attention
for if you do if those who have the
advantage of education
perspective and self-discipline do not
participate to the fullest extent of
their ability
america will stumble and if america
stumbles
the world falls
stevenson went on to say that we in our
country have placed all of our faith
all of our hopes on the intelligence
and the understanding of our people
he said we've bet all of our chips on
our on people
the american people it's a magnificent
gamble
but it's a gamble
if you think about it we all know people
who
say that the country's not going right
or this should have been done
or that should have been done but
the truth is if we want to know if we're
not comfortable
with the way the country's going the
only place we can look
is in the mirror
because it is to the people the american
people
that we have to look to to give
direction and guidance and indeed even
course corrections
to our country
i uh i've i haven't run for
office since the 1960s
it's a long time ago but i remember
when i was running people would say oh
i'm just one person
what can i do and the truth is
you can do a lot and
it requires people in public life it's
tough
it's not an easy job if if people want
to serve in those posts
at all levels federal state and local
if you do something somebody's not going
to like it
and a lot of people don't like to do
anything if somebody's not going to like
it
and and that's the nature of it some
people will like it but some people
won't and the people who won't
will probably be a little more
vociferous
than than the people that do so i i
mention this because
i always think of politics like throwing
a pebble in a pond
and the ripples go out and every person
sends out ripples and every person has a
lot more influence
as to the direction and course of our
country
and the outcome than we give ourselves
credit for
and i i hope people will go to the
website and take a look at that
speech because i think it i found it as
a
college senior inspiring and
i mention it today because i think an
awful lot of people
are saying this is horrible everything's
terrible
isn't penny penny the sky is falling
well i remember during president
johnson's presidency
there were people trying to break in the
white house
they had to put buses around the white
house to to block
people from trying to break in
think of that there were people
protesting day and night in washington
d.c
hey hey lbj how many kids did you kill
today it went on and on and on
when martin luther king was killed
the whole northeast section of
washington dc was a fire was burning
the city of detroit was the city of los
angeles was
i couldn't get across the bridge to my
house in washington
because the national guard had taken
over washington dc
blocked every bridge so what we're
seeing today
is a long way from the worst we've seen
set aside the civil war where 600 000
americans died
trying to preserve the union
so i i think it's it's unusual
where we are today i i can see that
i've never seen anything like it um
but we have a great country and it
it has to be rooted in the american
people
and it's going to take the best of all
of us everyone in this room and
all the people you know and all the
ripples that go out
when you decide that something's
important when you decide that
that you want to support somebody in
public office or you want to
point out that you don't agree with
someone in public office
but you're active you're engaged and you
give a darn
so i i think the the hand-wringing i see
today
is misplaced i think that
i guess we have so many academics here
that know
all these things but somebody i think is
said that democracy is the worst form of
government except for any other that's
ever been tried
and that's true but that means it's the
best
and it's the best only if each of you
pay attention
get engaged get involved say what you
think
and give a darn this this country is not
a driverless uber car
get with it all of you thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much
larry thinks he's going to try to answer
the questions i can't answer
is that right no no
i see well how do we do this you've got
microphones
people raise their hands someone walks
over with a microphone
they stand up they try to answer
ask a question instead of make a speech
that seems reasonable to me i'm not
trying to give you any calibration
right but just a hint
thank you for coming to speak with us uh
secretary rumsfeld
um like um like you i think
the go i think the decision to
liberate iraq in 2003 was a correct was
the correct decision but i'm curious to
see
um about of any evidence that you may
have know of that
of al the al qaeda presidents in iraq
that justified the invasion
of iraq the
basis for the decision by president bush
which he presented to the congress and
they agreed
uh the intelligence committee agreed he
presented to our allies
key allies with their own intelligence
information and they agreed
was based on the fact that saddam
hussein
he was a butcher to be sure and the
world's better without him let there be
no doubt of that but
but he had used uh chemical weapons on
his neighbors he'd use chemical weapons
on his own people the kurds
and the development of his programs were
such that
the president made the decision that
he shouldn't have those programs and
the lethality of those weapons is real
and
he uh what he what they found when it
was over was not
large stockpiles which may have been
destroyed
but what they they found a u.n inspector
named
dulfer came in and did an extensive
report with a team of people
and they found the facilities were
intact they were dual use but they were
intact
the precursors were intact
and the people who were involved had
been involved and were involved
were intact and together and uh
it it seems to me that he made the right
decision and
and uh people in both political parties
agreed with that
in the congress and uh uh
it turned out that the stockpiles large
stockpiles of these weapons were not
found
and uh and that's that's the reality
but it seems to me that
most people in public office
given similar intelligence information
and
ratification of that intelligence
information by people in the congress
and people
in allied countries would have made
probably the exact same decision that
president george w
bush made
uh first i'd like to thank you for being
here uh
this is actually a question from my dad
uh guys has
called her there saying that he was that
mr russell was going to be here
it's not you sure it's not your
grandmother
so no my dad was really excited
he's currently a colonel in the united
states air force tell him
thank you he uh
he's really excited to hear your words
or your thoughts
on uh radical islam and how and when
we should uh fight the ongoing threat
that is radical
tell them thank you very much for his
service i
um it seems to me that that we have to
be careful of the use of the word war
when we use the word war we think the
task is for the
army navy and air force and that we're
going to prevail with bullets
what we're dealing with is really
something much more
akin to communism and the cold war
than a hot war what we've got is
a a problem that
i don't believe you can prevail over
radical islam
and the johannes unless you're willing
to say that that's the problem
and that's the enemy and that's the
target it's not complicated
to pretend otherwise is to confuse
people in our country to weaken any
perseverance
or recognition that it's going to take
staying power we're not talking about a
short war
we're talking about a long war we're
talking about decades we're talking
about
changing people's minds we're talking
about not simply going out and shooting
people but
drying up the money tracking the money
stopping the recruiting process figuring
out
creative ways to deal with social media
where people today can
organize it's near instantaneously
and recruit through social media
you if you want to prevail you have to
decide
what it is you want to prevail over you
have to be willing to organize
and and equip and and
persuade lead and and you have to
demonstrate perseverance you have to
have a strategy
now everyone talks about strategy but i
see it on
boards in corporations i see in the
pentagon i see it in the white house
office of strategic thinking or
strategic operations or something
strategy is hard really hard stuff
first of all you got to decide what it
is you want to do you've got to have a
goal
and by golly if you pick a goal
somebody's not going to like it
and they're going to criticize it
they're going to fuss about it they're
going to fly spec it
and they're going to oppose you with
respect to that goal then you have to
look at
what are the assumptions underneath
achieving that goal
i mean take take a north korean war plan
the threat is that the north koreans
would come down and invade south korea
an ally and a friend of ours
that we're cooperating with and then you
say well you want to prevent that so
that's your goal
and then you have to say well what are
your assumptions are your assumptions
that the north koreans do or do not have
nuclear weapons have they weaponized
would the north koreans use or not use
nuclear weapons knowing
that they could be retaliated with
nuclear weapons
would the japanese diet agree or not
agree
to allow japanese airfields
used by the u.s to support the south
koreans in defending
so you've gotta you can't know the
answers to any of those things
but you have to make an assumption
because then you build
your your course of action decided based
on those
assumptions now unless you've done that
when the assumption changes which it
inevitably will
because you can't predict the future
then you know it's time to change your
course of action
you may even have to change your goal
so strategy is hard and most people
politicians don't like to do it
because if you do it somebody's not
going to like it they're going to
criticize it
and also if you set a goal you may not
get there
and then you're faulted for that so
strategy is something that everyone
talks about
who is it larry you'd know who who was
it who said everyone talks about the
weather but nobody does anything about
it
no it wasn't pat saget
it could have been
but i think it was either mark twain or
will rogers
no will rogers is the one who said my he
was part indian he said my
my family didn't come over on the
mayflower my family
met them i think he was part cherokee or
something but
question yes
you mentioned our motto strength
rejoices in the challenge
and i was wondering if you would tell us
the greatest challenge that you faced in
your career
how you overcame it and what it taught
you
how do you know i overcame it
and how do you know i learned anything
one would hope so
look first thing when you're 84 you
don't take
two-part questions
and when you've been around as long as i
have you
answer the questions you want to and you
don't answer the others
someone give me an easy one that's too
hard
who's next
someone asked me one day what's the
biggest mistake you've ever
made i said that's a terrible question
let me tell you the most brilliant thing
i ever did
and i answered that question
one day in a pentagon briefing some guy
asked me a terrible question
and i started talking and words came out
and i don't know
where i got all those words and finally
i admitted the truth
i said to him look i'm working my way
around the room trying to figure a
graceful way not to answer your question
i didn't do it very gracefully but
yes i promise this is only a one part
question
so you spoke again about giving a darn
about politics
and about about the government
would you say that possibly the issue of
morality is an issue that america may
face today such as the
kind of the assumption by some that
police the police force is an enemy to
america whereas they're trying to defend
it would you say that something that's
kind of
kind of central to um i guess some of
the issues that america is facing today
i don't know how well i ask that but
morality is central to america today
yes yes
well let me tell you why
we lead in this country not by command
but by consent
how do you achieve consent you achieve
consent by being persuasive
so you you make and this is true in the
military even the uniform military
that that it requires being persuasive
now what's the
bedrock of being persuasive it's being
believed
and concluding individually not only
that you believe the person
who's providing that direction or
guidance
but but that it fits with your values
and your inner beliefs and if something
doesn't
you resist it and if you don't believe
if the person isn't trustworthy and
trustful that you're convinced they're
truthful
that that what they're saying is is
right and and you learn that from
experience
you're not going to be persuaded and
you're not going to follow
so having a
a center of gravity having a
center at the core of a person
and and having a
a moral reference point that
is comfortable not just with you but
with
generally with the people you're trying
to lead is central it has to be
excuse me i was sitting right next to
you
and you didn't ask me anything
we're gonna we're gonna get someone way
in the back
after this
um in a few of the recent questions the
situation in the middle east has come up
and it seems to me that many of the
differences that lead to
war in the first place are differences
of first principles and of education
our motto or the last line of the honor
code here at hillsdale
is through education the student rises
to self-government
and i would through education the
student rises to self-government
and i was just wondering what your
thoughts are on the role of education in
war and conflict
well i think the the uh
the if you read that stevenson speech
i think the role of education in in
most things governmental um
is central we we have to rely on people
who
are educated and we have to rely on
systems
that teach people the things they need
to know
um i
i think that that government doesn't
work
except by consent
and government doesn't work except
having people in it
and people supporting those people in it
who have the backgrounds and the
understandings that come from a good
education
and and you you
you being a nice person isn't enough
being an older person isn't enough
in leadership it it requires
people who have been exposed to the
world exposed to experiences
exposed to
the the leadership and the the kind of
education that comes from reading the
great books and reading
and understanding i mean i almost said
something political
and i won't but i it is amazing
maybe i won't
but i i have to say i do wonder
if anyone's teaching economics anymore
in college or high school you look at
the number of people that go to a bernie
sanders speech
25 30 000 people
and there doesn't seem to be a
connection a link
between how that all happens
was that too political
why do you suppose larry standing up
here is he afraid i'll say something
wrong
is he going to give me the hook
let me say something so the answer is
yes i'm going to give him the hook when
it pleases me and second he asked me to
stand up here and then he criticized me
for it
a modus operandi
his memory is imperfect
question mr secretary thank you for your
leadership
and to that extent um major nadal hassan
during his residency at walter reed and
in his subsequent deployment
on his operational tour at fort hood
demonstrated multiple red flags those
red flags were
reported through the chain but the chain
failed to act
do you feel that at the senior level
both in the field and flag ranks that
we've become more concerned about
politics and political correctness
rather than the art
and principles of war and abrogated our
responsibilities for leadership
well i um as i recall it
the the carnage that resulted from his
behavior if i'm
my memory is correct it was called
workplace violence is that right
is that is that the incident that you
i've been out of government for 10 years
and i think it's only fair to say that
i'm not current
i'm not getting briefed i read what's in
the press as you do
i know from a long time in government
that an awful lot of what government's
doing
is known to the public as it should be
so i i'm probably not totally out of
date because i
i begin with a background in government
and in the department
of defense but i think it's not
unreasonable for people to
express the concern you've expressed
that we're spending an awful lot of time
on things that
please people who are interested in
correctness
and it may not be getting weighed
against effectiveness and balanced out
and made and the judgments made in a way
that that takes balance into account
rather than
one side of the argument and part of
that's because people
um how do you put this people who want
to
argue on one side are loud
noticed and energetic
active maybe is the word and people on
the other side
are somewhat less energetic less loud
less effective in arguing
and and people a lot of people don't
like to argue
they don't like to engage they're
uncomfortable
they don't want a conflict and if you've
got a clock
that's out there constantly
fly specking everything that gets done
i don't know what the number is today
but i was told by a former general
counsel of the pentagon that there's 10
000 lawyers in the pentagon
why well
they need them because everyone at every
level of
the chain of command is lawyered up
why are they lawyered up because they've
found from experience
that they have to be lawyered up
because they're constantly being
challenged they're constantly being
tested now i'm
as a law school dropout and i probably
shouldn't have mentioned that
but i did a question
he says i can do one or two more if he
likes the answer
mr secretary thank you so much for being
here college tonight um
my question is how should the next
president of the united states and their
administration best utilize the military
for foreign policy objectives and
threats facing the united states
those are tough calls and those are
calls that the president makes
as to what you need
or should or might best do in tough
situations
and it's a those are tough jobs it's a
complicated world we live
in i was in a
country in greater central asia last
june
four or five months ago and one of the
people in the audience
asked the one of the ministers from that
country
a simple question if you could had the
opportunity
to give advice to the president of the
united states who's coming in this
january coming january what would you
say
and this minister without batting an
eye from a totally foreign country
said act like a superpower
you you cannot
contribute to a leadership vacuum or it
gets filled by somebody with
views and interests and behavior
patterns
that are not in our interest the
countries around the world
that have anything approximating
a free economic system or a relatively
free political system
or any country that may not have a free
political or a free economic system
but benefits from a relatively stable
world not stable but
relatively stable they're frightened
when they see
a vacuum created because they know it's
going to get filled
and it struck me that that that minister
in that country said it exactly right
that doesn't mean go be policemen of the
world it doesn't mean go get invaded
engaged in wars and conflicts and
try to pretend and i would add that i
don't think it means
that we should take our template that
we've arrived at
in the year 2016 and think
that we should press it down on other
countries we shouldn't
the template we've arrived at today is
not what we had 50
years ago or 100 years ago it's not what
we're going to have in 50 years from now
we've we're evolving just like they do
these other countries have
they have different neighbors they have
different cultures they have different
languages
they have different political
circumstances and it's not for us to
to to beat our chess and make a judgment
that what we've got is right
but if you want a visible
a stark example of what works
and what doesn't work my office has got
a satellite photo
in fact it's in my book my my memoir
a satellite photo of the korean
peninsula
you've got this dmz in the middle
demilitarized zone
i've promised i won't use acronyms
i i've told people that this is an
acronym-free zone so i apologize
i apologize for saying dmz it's the
demolitorized zone
same people north and south same
language
same neighbors same history same culture
and you look at that satellite photo and
there's electricity and energy down
south
and in the north there's a pin prick of
light in the capital of pyang
they're starving up north and the south
korean
economy is the 13th largest economy on
the face of the earth
it is a stunning photograph
and anyone who can't figure out that a
freer political system
not necessarily our model today but
opting towards a freer political system
and a freer economic system
is so vastly better than an
authoritarian system
or a communist command economy
uh it it the photograph says it all
and it seems to me that it's important
that we
we get a little preachy
sometimes as a country um
if if if there's the world
and this is quote by our current
standard bad
not good not like us is what we really
mean when we say bad
we're judgmental and this is good and
some country is over here in the
in the bad half but they're moving in
this direction
towards freer political systems and free
or economic systems it seems to me
you want to encourage that
you don't want to say well you're not
perfect you're not just like we are
you have to be just like we are well
that's silly
different countries at different times
need different political systems
they may very well even need different
economic systems
so we have to be careful about thinking
that
that we've always been what we are now
or that will always be i mean
women didn't vote into that 1900s we
still had slaves in this country in the
1800s
and and we're still evolving and
changing
and who knows what will look like in
another 50 or 100 years
so we shouldn't expect others to be
exactly like we are
and we shouldn't preach to them and tell
them they'll
now if you show them the korean
peninsula from a satellite
at night an untrained
ape ought to see what works
and what doesn't work
[Applause]
secretary rumsfeld thank you very much
for your speech tonight
my question is i guess somewhat
strategic so i'll
press you and i know you're not
currently engaged but
as we look at our global situation in
manufacturing
and our movement of manufacturing
overseas
and i look at world war ii and our
ability to produce whatever we wanted to
produce
to meet our challenges facing us at that
point
what is your opinion relative to our
ability to
address that if the balloon goes up
again
well i don't even slightly doubt
but that the united states could
mobilize and produce the kinds of things
and
technologies and capabilities that we
would need
if in fact it became clear that we
needed them
there's something about things that are
gradual
where we don't address them and it takes
leadership and it takes brains and it
takes insight
and it takes some of the things that
shelling wrote in that forward
to figure out what's important
but in a crisis people get out of their
chairs
and they say my goodness the pendulum's
gone too far one way
so i'm willing to turn off the
television or stop doing what i'm doing
and invest time
pushing that pendulum back where it
belongs and and that's happened
every time we have
faced a crisis in this country
and it's been impressive now
is it a different world today yeah it is
it's a different world
we we are the lethality of weapons has
become increasingly lethal every year
the technologies that very few countries
in the world can create and develop
and design we tend to sell
off the shelf to anyone who wants them
they couldn't development most the
countries couldn't develop those things
but they could
buy them and use them to their advantage
which may or may not be
our best interest
and as i say maybe i'm just too much of
an optimist
but there is not a doubt in my mind
but that a leadership
that that indicated that there was a
need
and it was persuasive and believable and
truthful
in describing that need would be able to
energize this country
and get it pointed and off in the right
direction
you know there's a tendency for people
to say oh where are the great leaders
you look around and you're uncomfortable
with this person or uncomfortable with
that person
i spoke at the u.s army association back
in sometime in the 1980s and
i i titled the speech where are the
great leaders
and and i pointed out that throughout my
early life in the 1930s
people served in the military
and it was tough these these people
would be lieutenants
for seven eight years they were dragging
their wives and their kids and their
spouses around
from lousy dusty bases in one
city to another place in another state
day
we year after year they'd get
transferred and they'd go do that
no one knew who they were no one gave a
darn
the military was not respected
and and world war ii comes we're
attacked in japan
and lo and behold who was there
hap arnold was there
admiral leahy was there
admiral king was there general macarthur
was there
general patton was there
think of that they were there all the
time
and they're there today
and they'll be there when they're needed
even though
today we don't know their names maybe
but believe me they're there and this is
a great country
and and i have every confidence in the
world
that people who have the benefit of an
education in this school
this college and the people who support
it
are wise enough to know that that is a
value
that's important it seems to me that
that we're
it's understandable if we worry when we
see
things not going the way we might like
them but by golly at bedrock
this is a great country the people are
great people
and we're going to do what needs to be
done and thank you very much
he's good